[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture tout le
sommaire de ce mardi 4 décembre
patienter avant noël c'est aussi
possible en culture longue et le micro
de veigy villacoublay vous invitent à
leur festival un air de famille ni
spectacles et performances sont au
rendez vous pour cette saison le prisme
d'elancourt mise sur le rire et propose
même une soirée 100% humour artistes
amateurs et reconnue vont se partager la
scène le temps d'une soirée son
troisième album anti slogan est sorti en
début d'année cheval rex est une des
figures montantes de la scène pop
française
ils jouent ce week-end à la batterie
lors de cette page musicale nous
parlerons aussi d'axel bauer le chanteur
de cargos ou encore éteint la lumière
sera en concert à montigny le bretonneux
avec décembre arrive les célébrations
des fêtes de fin d'année les centres
d'art et salles de spectacles sont de la
partie
le micron deslondes de
vélizy-villacoublay vous propose toute
une programmation jusqu'au 21 décembre
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images pour ces fêtes de noël le micro
ondes et le théâtre d'une histoire
d'amour celle de ses deux bonhommes de
neige une oeuvre en perpétuel mouvement
pensé par les sculpteurs cléda et petit
pierre on travaille les choses qui nous
qui nous qui nous tiennent à coeur
notamment beaucoup sur le
la fabrication fabrique tout nous mêmes
on a vraiment un grand bassin grand
temps en atelier et puis après il ya
cette histoire de couple qui est la
nôtre quand même cette histoire d'amour
et voilà ça tourne autour de comment on
fait comment habiter la sculpture voilà
et on a trouvé ce mode là et on est
vraiment à mi chemin entre la sculpture
et le vivant on est très intéressé par
le corps par et on est très intéressé
aussi par là par la sculpture par les
volumes des performances à découvrir
jusqu'au 21 décembre le micron deslondes
vous font vivre l'avant en famille
depuis trois ans avec le festival un air
de famille
pas vraiment accès et la programmation
sur la famille et surtout le spectacle
jeunesse alors que ce soit du spectacle
vivant ou des arts plastiques comme ici
c'est une invitation aux enfants à venir
avec leurs parents et découvrir voilà le
spectacle le théâtre la danse des
spectacles à vivre dès l'âge de 2 ans le
prochain rendez-vous vous fera tomber du
ciel le mercredi 5 décembre avec un
conte chorégraphique librement inspiré
du petit prince d'antoine de
saint-exupéry
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez aussi pouvoir patienter avant
les fêtes à saint quentin en yvelines la
commanderie vous invite à noël décalé
des ateliers à faire en famille un bar
pour échanger et des temps musicaux et
c'est de ces derniers dont on va parler
avec nos invités juliette dit jean et
pascal romano ou bonjour bonsoir l'orgie
legends est la directrice du rayonnement
culturel de saint quentin en yvelines
un nouvel événement à la commanderie oui
tout à fait donc la commanderie
c'est un lieu qui est consacrée à la
programmation d'événements culturels
mais pas que des événements atypiques et
donc nous avons souhaité pour la période
de fin d'année proposé un événement qui
puisse rassembler un maximum d'habitants
notamment pourquoi pas les gens qui se
sentent un peu seuls
à cette période de l'année est donc
proposé un ensemble d'opérations
qui vont de l'exposition de sapins
d'artistes contemporains par exemple
jusqu'à une programmation de concerts de
musique d'ensemble d'où le nom de
l'opération noël ensemble
alors justement ces instants musicaux
chaque soir un ensemble vocal est un
ensemble instrumental parce qu'elle
remet maintenant vous vous signez la
direction artistique de ces rendez vous
comment vous les avez pensé on les a
pensé sur les ressources qu'on
connaissait déjà sur le territoire qui
sont nombreuses et qui ont qui n'ont
jamais été vraiment rassembler sur un
temps comme sadoul l'intitulé ensemble
également il y a eu un fort engouement
pour ce projet et nous avons réussi à
monter d'ores et déjà dans un temps très
court a néanmoins un temps un temps
d'appel très court 4 4 journées quatre
journées quatre soirées qui sont
articulées en effet sur un temps
instrumentale et un temps vocal tous les
soirs donc le public pourra venir
découvrir des ensembles peut-être un peu
méconnu mais du moins qui sont présents
sur le territoire et donc ce sont d'une
part les associations les conservatoires
et toutes les ressources qui ont été
appelés à participer à ce temps qui est
conclue par un temps fort le samedi
autour d'une fanfare qui viendra nous
pour que tu es cet événement cette année
un fort engouement c'est à dire qu'il a
fallu faire des choix j'ai imaginé dans
les candidatures
il a fallu faire des choix mais nous
savons déjà que c'est ce n'est que
partie remise puisque beaucoup
souhaitaient aussi s'inscrire dans la
durée et qui se sont donc inscrits ou
pré inscrits et déjà même pour les
années à venir
et voilà non mais c'est un choix qui
malgré tout on a on a joué la diversité
c'est à dire qu'on va avoir de la
musique ancienne on va avoir des
ensemble de saxophones on va avoir du
cabaret on va avoir de la fanfare on va
avoir des ensembles vocaux
tous se sont inscrits néanmoins dans la
thématique du lieu qui 2
de la période qui l'ol décalé donc tous
je pense vont jouer le jeu d'un
programme
peut-être traditionnel mais pas que et
vont nous montrer toutes les facettes de
leur talent didierjean c'est un moyen
c'est de faire découvrir les artistes
locaux les talents locaux
le projet de la commanderie c'est un
projet qui est porté par des services
culturels de l'agglomération danse
itinéraire poétique sciences et arts
mais le projet c'est aussi de fédérer
les énergies du territoire enfin celle
en tout cas qu'ils veulent bien nous
rejoindre et notamment au travers
d'associations et donc moi je remercie
les ensembles qui nous ont répondu
qu'ils s'inscrivent dans cette
programmation donc ça permet à la fois
de donner une visibilité la richesse
culturelle de ce qui se fait au travers
des amateurs de les associer un ensemble
professionnel est effectivement d'avoir
une approche de la culture un petit peu
différente
souvent quand on parle de culture la
plupart même de nos amis
s'impose de plus en plus une vision
élitiste ce que n'est pas du tout le
projet la lidc on est bien la
commanderie il se passe toujours quelque
chose à la commanderie et on peut
investir un lieu qui n'est pas
nécessairement adaptée mais où il ya la
culture ne rentre et peut-être pas
nécessairement avant il y avait une
programmation culturelle mais avec moins
de d'agents pour la mettre en oeuvre
donc elle était certainement un peu plus
confidentielle mais néanmoins de qualité
la lidc d'intensifier la programmation
est d'avoir des événements atypiques
tels par exemple si je peux citer un
événement qui va se passer dans le cadre
d'une nouvelle décalée un artiste qui
est benoît race ouf qui a construit un
sauna un soda mobile et il considère que
son oeuvre d'art est une oeuvre d'art
vivante à partir du moment où les
usagers peuvent utiliser ce sauna qui
fonctionne donc pendant la période de
noël le 15 et 16 décembre
les gens qui le souhaitent pourront
s'inscrire pour faire un sauna dans le
sauna mobile de nouara baignoire à ceux
là va partout je voudrais juste conclure
un tout petit peu sur les ensembles
vocaux les eaux sont vocaux et
instrumentaux précis bien c'est un
concert par sort d'une heure environ
vous avez fait une programmation en
fonction des styles vous voulez qu'ils
se répondre au contraire que ce soit
complètement différent pour amener un
certain public plus important
je voulais une diversité par soir doudou
l'aspect instrumental et vocal ça
commence le ce projet là le mercredi 14
19h30 c'est tous les soirs le même
horaire 19h30 20h30 une heure pendant
cette heure là le temps est partagé en
sur ces deux moments là et nous allons
avoir
je vais peut-être laisser la surprise le
programme va sortir très vite d'ailleurs
j'invite le public à s'inscrire parce
que la jauge voilà le bâtiment enfin le
lieu qui est adapté qui est qui est
aménagé n'accueille pas louper un public
exhaustif c'est un temps court c'est un
temps de partage en effet c'est un temps
à mon avis où il faut venir découvrir et
je pense que chaque soir le public
trouvera soit une découverte soit une
soit un moment agréable à passer
toujours de manière variée c'est le
concept delà du temps proposé autour
dans un premier temps d'un temps
instrumentale et en conclusion un temps
vocale et tout ça en une heure et on va
terminer il nous reste quelques secondes
encore vous avais prédit sonia parce que
saskia des animations artistiques autour
de l'arbre tout à fait on installe un
arbre hameau dans la cour de la
commanderie et chacun ensemble adultes
parents grands parents on peut venir
écrire un petit mot mettre un dessin
dans une boule transparente qui est
accroché dans l'arbre et je signale
aussi des ateliers de création de
lanternes en forme de lotus lantern
lumineuse qui auront lieu ce samedi tous
les renseignements sont sur kiosque.fr
tout et tout et donne et merci à tous
les deux des traditions ce plateau alors
le noël décalé débute le 8 décembre à la
commanderie à elancourt et le premier
concert ensemble c'est le mercredi tous
décembre à 19h30
ce dimanche c'était la cérémonie de
clôture du festival du film documentaire
saint quentin huit films étaient en
compétition trois d'entre eux ont été
primés
vincent amoureux et alex baril ont reçu
le prix tv dessous soixante dix huit
pour le disent et interstellaire les
cinémas ont choisi de distinguer
télescope intérieur de virgile novarina
et niels had a quant à lui été
doublement primé pour l'aventuré
aéronautique des bleus par trois y est
c'est le public on les écoute
je suis très content et très étonné à
vrai dire je m'y attendais pas trop
quand j'ai vu les autres films qui
étaient en compétition
mon film a été réalisé dans une optique
qui était plus axé sur la communication
l'événement du tour aérien des jeunes
pilotes qui a lieu donc tous les deux
ans et qui est organisée par la
fédération française aéronautique et
donc j'ai essayé de suivre des certains
jeunes pilotes en l'occurrence trois ou
quatre et c'est vrai que ça dure 15
jours mais c'est très intensifs
c'est une première reprise modèle en
cours une soirée 100% humour un show
unique animé par papy et julie sheth
pour découvrir les talents de demain et
la directrice du prisme est avec nous en
plateau pour en parler jeune neymar son
bonjour bonjour pourquoi vous avez
choisi de mettre l'humour en avant alors
pourquoi on a choisi de l'être l'humour
en avant de l'humour il n'a toujours eu
au prisme
c'est vrai que là cette saison entre ce
nouveau projet qui démarre donc ce soir
et puis la programmation d'humoristes on
va dire plus reconnus on sûrement dû
noter qu'il ya une large place qui est
fait qui est fait à l'humour mais pas
n'importe lequel on a choisi
d'accueillir des humoristes voilà pour
lesquels on avait
un gros coup de coeur qui on voit des
choses à raconter qu'ils sont dans dans
l'esprit en tout cas qu'on essaie d'en
porter aux prises mais toujours dans
l'optique aussi d'être sur une
programmation pluridisciplinaire à
direction d'un public voilà familiale
divers éclectique
voilà comme doit être interdit de ville
sur scène ce cap des 100 me lie à des
artistes reconnus mais aussi de jeunes
tout l'artiste
alors là la particularité là avec
7-8 humour donc on a conçu en
partenariat avec tv 78 et
c'est en tout cas sa part de l'idée
aigles envie de valoriser les talents du
territoire donc de jeunes artistes en
devenir qui sont pas encore
professionnel qui pour beaucoup ont pas
de spectacle formalisé qui ont encore
été pas encore été rodé on qu'on a passé
un appel à candidatures le principe
était de nous envoyer une petite vidéo
3000 ya bien fonctionné qu'à bien
fonctionné on a eu pas mal de réponses y
compris de jeunes gens qui n'ont pas du
territoire ça participe aussi voilà de
l'attractivité à tort ça quand on est
venu et du prisme de pouvoir accueillir
comme ça des jeunes gens de tous
horizons
même si évidemment on a une attention
portée aux jeunes qui sont issus de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de trappes des
lampes humour de montigny voilà
évidemment et donc de valoriser toutes
et tous ces jeunes
et puis de leur associer aussi des
artistes la voilà qui plus plus accompli
qui voit là ont déjà réalisé leur
premier spectacle qui tourne aujourd'hui
voilà sur les scènes d'humour parisienne
et provinciales et que donc d'arriver
sur un plateau un peu éclectique assez
joyeux avec différentes formes d'humour
différentes personnalités ont un endroit
de partage ces jeunes ils ont été
accompagnés une fois choisis où on les a
laissés présenter ce qu'ils avaient
envie
alors on a eu un premier temps de
travail en fait via une quinzaine de
jours avec papilles et julie où les
jeunes qui ont pu se rendre disponible
du coup sont venus une après midi nous
ont présenté ce qu'ils avaient
l'intention du coup de présenter ce soir
il ya eu un temps d'accompagnement de
regard extérieur de conseil de la part
de julie et pas jeter ces noms c'est la
tradition à qui on donne un site c'est
de prendre du temps à la fois en amour
mais aussi en aval c'est-à-dire qu'après
le spectacle de ce soir il y aura un
retour aussi forcément qui leur sera
fait
la captation télé 78 réaliser leur
permettre de se voir voilà et dans de
bonnes conditions donc tout ça mis bout
à bout constitue quand même pour eux à
la une
une jolie expérience un beau tremplin où
les avait nommé alain degois pape il
sait on le connaît plus facilement sous
ce nom là julie chaise pourquoi eux
pourquoi elle pour lui c'est une jeune
metteur en scène que j'ai rencontrés
voilà sur d'autres projets car la
particularité à la fois de travailler
sur des projets vont dire plus sérieux
puisque elle met en scène aussi du
répertoire discutait contemporain et
c'est là dessus qu'on s'était rencontrés
et double casquette
elle travaille aussi sur un spectacle
qui s'appelle le grand show time avec
plein d'humoriste elle fait le délicieux
de l'impro julie et ce spectacle du cou
qui est diffusée au grand point virgule
aux petits points en jeu
laquelle des deux scènes qui est
diffusée depuis des années qu'elle un
succès voilà et qui est vraiment dans
l'esprit de ce que nous avons souhaité
apporter
et puis ces deux réseaux aussi
différents papiers julie ce qui nous
permettait voilà de faire travailler à
la fois
plus en lien avec le territoire une
histoire de papiers et puis voilà une
ouverture autres et puis très important
un homme une femme sur la taxe anti
justement papier était l'invité de
grégory canal et sur le journal du 3
décembre je vous propose de l'écouter
pendant le set 8 humour c'est aussi de
se dire que ce territoire et qui a été
quand même assez riche en talents
notamment humour je vais pas rappeler
tout ce j'ai suivi mais il y en a un
petit nom un petit nombre c'est jamel
debbouze y en a besoin mais 10 à doumbia
arnaud tsamère tous ces gens sophia aram
tous ces gens qui viennent de ce terroir
font que je me suis dit et c'est pour ça
que virginie est venu me chercher aussi
il ya il ya forcément encore une
richesse là qui est pas encore assez
exploité pour moi cette richesse on va
donc la voir ce soir le premier volet
puisque l'idée c'est de continuer et
d'avoir plusieurs rendez-vous comme ça
en fait pendant la saison donc 3 3
plateaux sont posés sur la saison en
cours
et puis d'autres suivront l'année
prochaine avec peut-être peut-être c'est
en discussion l'idée de les faire
tourner de manière nomade sur les salles
d'autres salles partenaires de saint
quentin en yvelines
on le disait tout à l'heure c'est aussi
à l'image de la saison du prisme il ya
notamment neuf dates d'humour et pas des
mois on à alex vizorek françois xavier
demaison manu payet pour ne citer qu'eux
c'est dur de citer tout le monde c'était
une volonté d'aller aussi est de faire
rire votre public
oui c'est une demande aussi de nos
spectateurs d'avoir accès
voilà des grands noms de l'humour
aujourd'hui sur leur territoire dans
leur théâtre à de faire vivre ce
territoire pour tous les publics
et c'est à la fois vous l'avez dit 1,9
date d'humour mais autant danse en
théâtre en jeune public voilà l'idée
c'est vraiment d'ouvrir au maximum avec
ce soit le théâtre de tous les élan pour
toi et plus largement aussi toujours de
5 enfin quand même
voilà merci virginie marsan d'avoir
accepté notre invitation la soirée déjà
victime de son succès de son succès mais
vous pouvez la retrouver prochainement
sur notre antenne des concerts pour
faire patienter les fans avant le
prochain album axel bauer sera sur l'a7
la scène de la salle jacques-brel de
montigny le bretonneux le 8 décembre
prochain
l'occasion de redécouvrir ces anciens
titres mais aussi les plus récents nous
l'avons rencontré à l'hôtel le pigalle à
paris
[Musique]
axel beaux arts est avant tout un
amoureux de la guitare celui dont la
voix rauque a marqué les années 80 90 ne
cesse de composer en s'inspirant de cet
instrument
je travaille toujours beaucoup de la
guitare et je dois dire que j'ai pas
toujours été assidu dans ce travail là
j'étais très assidus entre eux on va
dire 15 et 22 ans et puis après ma
carrière a démarré avec cargo et puis
après ça a pris le relais ça a pris une
différentes formes la vida dur ma
passion et je je m'exprime en tant qu
improvisateurs en sur scène à travers
des solos à des parties guitare sur les
routes depuis 2007 l'artiste défend son
dernier album live in ferber enregistrés
dans les célèbres studios parisiens un
mélange alternant ses titres célèbres et
autres morceaux tirés de sept précédents
albums
il n'y avait pas eu de live de dans mon
travail et dans les années j'étais chez
universal ce n'était pas d'actualité
ça manquait je pense à ma discographie
est d'autant que
vous voyez un titre comme éteint la
lumière aujourd'hui en version live il a
plus de vue sur sur youtube que la
version originale parce que je pense que
la version que je joue aujourd'hui de ce
morceau est sur ce live à ferber
correspond plus à ce que je voulais
faire quand dans les années 90 que je
n'ai pas fait à ce moment-là un prochain
album est en préparation pour l'année
2019 avant de le découvrir
axel bauer continue sa tournée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on continue à parler musique avec notre
nouvel invité cheval rex rémy poncet de
son vrai nom mongeau bonjour alors vous
serez sur la scène de la batterie de
guyancourt le 7 décembre prochain un
concert on va pouvoir découvrir les
titres de votre dernier album notamment
anti slogan tout à fait ce qu'il ya
possibilité de présenter un petit peu
pour le concert de vendredi c'est assez
j'ai l'habitude de faire mal de concerts
dans plusieurs formules différentes donc
des fois on arrive en groupe des fois je
fais des concerts tout seul et la
vendredi on sera deux et comme les
disques sont pas mal l'orchestré avec
des cordes et cuivres tout est un peu
réinventer réarrangés pour le concert
c'est justement au tout début il s'est
retrouvé au début vous travaillez sur
tout tout seul vous êtes vous êtes
ouvert un peu plus un grand groupe vous
êtes rencontrés sur ce disque-là ouais
mais en fait les trois premiers disques
à la la c'est mon troisième qui sorti en
mars
le parcours et c'est une petite petite
croissance on va dire stage de promised
évron mois seul dans ma chambre dans la
drôme où j'enregistrais le second
c'était toujours moi seul qui enregistre
un peu tout mais c'est il ya eu enfin de
fans chaîne que le cac est mixé on avait
refait des voix et c est là le nouveau
disque que j'ai toujours la même base
moi qui commence à enregistrer chez tout
seul et mais assez vite je me suis
content avec des musiciens et c'est donc
du coup le voilà ces trois disent que là
on peut sentir que le son est l'écriture
s'ouvre d'un coût de plus en plus moi
j'ai vu que le départ de cet album ce
serait une lecture de simone de beauvoir
qu'est ce qui vous a plu chez cette
basse et fascine c'est une rencontre une
coïncidence alors ça fait j'avais dit
j'ai lu pas mal de bribes de mais jamais
un livre complet et sur ce dernier
disque là il ya vraiment un peu plus
assumer la partie écriture enfin
littéraire des textes
enfin j'ai ma culture est très liée à la
musique instrumentale des choses comme
ça donc j'ai toujours très plutôt mis ça
en amont et sur ce dernier disque là où
il ya vraiment le l'envi de mettre en
avant le texte
et au moment où j'ai commencé à écrire
le ce disque là j'ai lu je j'attaquais
en fait les cycles de roman biographique
donc il y en a six je crois et ça a été
assez dévorant comme comme lecture et du
coup j'étais en train d'écrire en même
temps il y avait elle qui parlait de l
apprendre la personne et c'est quelque
chose que bach a toujours été important
pour moi ça ce rapport l'autoportrait
l'autobiographie donc il ya eu une
espèce de discussions entre elle et moi
même si elle est plus là qui s'installe
et je propose qu'on écoute un extrait de
cet album et on discute après
de l'enfer
et apporte rien
[Musique]
vraiment
ici non
juste un visa
plein
quittant seul
du soir au matin ça maintenant des
sauvages vous interroger sur vous dans
vos titres parce que vous parler à la
première personne vous voit vous mettez
beaucoup en selle c'est une réflexion
c'est sur vous même je crois que je
serai pas réellement faire autrement
en vrai pour dire la vérité je veux dire
quand j'écris je suis pas du tout dans
la fiction ni à la fois je suis pas non
plus dans quelque chose de très
descriptif de ce que je vis mais il ya
une sorte d'état je vois pas comment
parler du monde autrement qu'à travers
mon prix sema mois en fait donc j'essaie
toujours de contourner le l'écueil de
parler que de soi et de faire un disque
un peu nombriliste c'est ça qui m'a
touché aussi chez de beauvoir c'est
qu'il ya un élan qui est bien plus large
que juste parler de soi mais met
effectivement en même temps les clips
effectivement qu'on voit l'image j'ai
besoin d'être là en fait pendant très
longtemps j'ai plutôt été un peu un peu
planqué à faire mettre mes disques dans
mon coin et là je crois qu'il ya une
vraie un vrai besoin de se libérer aussi
d'assumer ça en fait voilà c'est moi qui
fais ça maintenant on l'a entendu votre
propre votre pop elle est plutôt
intimiste on est très vite versé par
votre voix et il ya un côté minimaliste
ceci ça qu'on s'attache à la première
matière la voix la musique et on n'avait
pas trop loin engluée dans trop de
musique peut-être trop d'offres j'aime
assez cette idée qu au final je puisse
être juste là pas loin d'une oreille et
raconter quelque chose assez intime fin
de l'histoire de la proximité avec
l'auditeur mai
après comme utilisateur je suis très
attaché à la partie instrumentale des
choses donc j'ai tendance à vraiment
composé la musique avant d'écrire et
souvent de me faire embarquer assez loin
en terme d'heures castration avec des
cordes
donc il ya vraiment ses fournisseurs
d'équipements fait comment trouver cette
place entre un élan un peu un peu
lyrique dans la musique
et puis une classe plus vrai plus
intimiste plus simple on apparaître ces
mots de mouvements de beauvoir pain de
gigue recommande que par lui vos
inspirations au niveau 6 de dominique à
qui vous a marqué dans votre enfance par
la qualité des textes par qu'est ce qui
vous a plu laquelle est oui enfin si
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir un grand frère
qui écoutait beaucoup de très chouettes
musique et donc je assez tôt 11 12 ans
j'ai découvert toute une nouvelle scène
française qui était dominique a miossec
catherine donc j'ai vraiment grandi avec
ses figures la de chanteur en france
sans me dire que c'était forcément des
des auteurs enfin et c'était l'été que
c'était vraiment important toujours
approche musicale parce que j'écoutais
aussi beaucoup de musique anglo saxonne
ministre mentale et mais c'est qu'avec
le temps en fait je me dis mais
finalement j'écoute pas tant de chansons
françaises aujourd'hui puisque souvent
je suis rebutés par les mots et cela
reste donc c'est bien clore leurs mots à
eux sont un peu plus en tout cas moi me
parle davantage quoi merci réponse est
non je le rappelle on peut vous écoutez
le vendredi 7 décembre prochain sur la
scène de la batterie de guillon cours on
passe maintenant à notre agenda
[Musique]
et on continue en musique avec notre
premier rendez vous à l'espace albert
camus où vous pourrez écouter une
artiste au timbre particulier avec sa
voix alto robin mckelle est
régulièrement comparé à aretha franklin
ou tina turner et pour l'écouter
direction l'espace albert camus de
maurepas à l'extrait du gard
[Musique]
m
paris 7 sept
doyoubuzz whishaw kf3
[Musique]
sur scène 20 comédienne qui raconte
l'histoire d'une adolescente victime de
harcèlement ses fils à s'inspire de la
vie d'un mandat tonnes une jeune
canadienne qui se suicident en 2012
l'oeuvre est à découvrir à la ferme de
bel ébat de guyancourt regardez ici le
magazine nous c'est la fin de ce site
une culture merci de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve mardi prochain
[Musique]